how come you're not wearing your
sneakers I'd wear my new sneakers I'd
show them off know what you Doug yeah
but you're making I mean tons of money
if I remember correctly for your last
special you bought like I bought Easy's
ten pairs the easiest temper is the
easier online to get the right pair you
did buy ten pairs I did so I'm wearing
easy than my old my new special I'm
wearing easy have you watched the
Netflix special Jim is wearing do you
mean Travis Travis to do that but Travis
no he's Eminem's easy easy
call me you're asking for size I think
they're eights
yes No
Oh Travis is going to get him you had it
oh you left some here yeah I said a
couple pairs who lives here the ones the
one I wore in the special I have at home
as long as I stay away from you okay
well see what their ties they're easy
how much did you want to how much would
you pay for
Easy's they're just like the fifty
seventy-five bunk so do you have a nine
and a half no I think just eight or
eight and a half for athletes though
Easy's are fragile
yeah yeah I'm glad I said forget that I
still had a pair here if you want to buy
them or something am I gonna wear em I
think they all didn't fit I didn't know
exactly what size I was and I was in a
kind of a crunch and right and I think
you got a couple different links what
matches with what yeah yeah he'll bring
do you think you're gonna have to haggle
with the boss or do you think he'll just
accept your first price no I mean I'm
not gonna haggle with him I'll give on
selling for higher than I paid for him
but I'm not going to you know right I
gotta take so how much are we talking I
don't know I don't remember much I paid
for him here's the new bond
he's even open Travis we open them yeah
yeah yeah my voice like I'm yeah mm-hmm
those are actually nice too and they've
they've gone up in value
they're like genie shoes they're unworn
those are called loser
we refer to those as dead stocked what
does that mean it just means that like
unworn you basically get them out there
what you would get from a shoe store
when they first came out there talk okay
do they fit rich is trying to squeeze
into the size feet you have
- yeah baby riches - nine eight and a
half to nine yeah so eights probably
give me a little tight yeah are those
eight ridges trying to squeeze into him
how do you get hurt putting shoes on
yourself the [ __ ] is hurt
rich is grabbing his bicep hurt his
bicep putting on a pair of easy [ __ ]
creep if you could get him on yeah but
just just just don't walk in them yeah
he's got the cool rich of a cool poll
shows how much they sell for Yeezys I
didn't know I mean I paid a lot for
these you can go to stock XCOM how much
they easy in Stockholm that's that's the
site that I so I'll give them to vouch
for less obvious I'm like a song ah too
bad you could squeeze into him do it
just wear them on stage like you don't
even to walk around I might still have
another pair you're eight-and-a-half she
probably bigger than me I might have one
more pair at home there's a couple I
throw at night is about yeah why not
I'll give you half it I don't give a
[ __ ] they just sit in the office you
know what do people buy these things yes
yeah yeah there they are they're $1,000
right now yeah and they're gonna go up
people know they were tried on by rich
Voss online rich I'll give you half the
money because it right now they're
sitting in the office I would I would
yeah whatever you want from 850 to 2500
you can honestly wait if you don't want
to go through all the trouble of selling
them online there are places in the city
that are like I'm not walking in with
sneakers I just can't Sam told me I
should walk you know pleasure these
sneakers and sell if they're new and
those are new you can't tell them it is
cuz you're thinking I'm not gonna
restore sneakers like let's see what we
do understand over 30 years you turn
okay
a lot of money I know I'll give you half
I I will give you half if you go to like
stadium goods or I hear cop first drop
what's that what's that place I go to
they what they do is they'll buy like
Yeezys or supreme stuff and then they'll
resell it but yeah see like they have
easy these originally cost I don't
remember I bought a bunch of them and I
had I had money dollars 200 now I paid
for my memory I bought like four five
pairs presented no it's nice in a panic
so shooting like a week later so I just
bought them so I have two pair to wear
yeah if you go to one of the like the
top sneaker stores in New York Life
Stadium Goods or flight club they have
like connected to the store I put a
country in it it'll stretch right Shuchi
will stretch to yes you might have to
wear a pair of sneakers I won't talk to
you yeah it's not an emergency night and
it might be emergency she's dropping the
first letters of words today get some on
radio that's great good bye yeah hello
which congratulations yes more than
people did for her when she was just
think when she married you and people
didn't congratulate her I was tripping
up my eagerness nickname was named after
these sneakers her nickname was after
thinking of what was that easy get it no
I didn't get it I got it let's go yes
good so what are the stories stamina
with them and I connect a lot either
stadium goods or flight where those
stadium Goods down down towards the Soho
area this is all like hip-hop culture
like like is that kind of what maybe
culture I don't get it sneaker culture
is almost a culture in and of itself no
you stuff like this [ __ ] supreme I'm
so out of it not that anybody looks at
address Street where culture okay Doug
do you get any of this or no no in Los
Angeles in the Fairfax District there's
like a couple different places that
there's lines down the block all the
time it's it's there's constantly a new
shoe yeah that's worth lining up for I
like
on Fairfax that's where the hundred
store is and they like cross-promote
with other brands like the lake on on
the last Friday to the 13th they made a
line of like t-shirts and hoodies that
were Friday the 13th just based on the
movie and they just sold out instantly
it's really Henderson occurs at my shows
you what pretend I'm selling sneakers at
my shows to get some lines outside
sneakers at my shows is way too many
asses I'll give you half I'm not gonna
walk in and do it today from a store
like that that's why what they do they
know exactly yeah standing outside the
in New Brunswick they won't sell them
for quite as much money so I won't be
able to buy him for koalas actually at
lunch I also think in the city they're
[ __ ] more likely to get a pair of
sneakers without a receipt and not give
a [ __ ] right probably trade Dee's I
don't know I'm smiling because I love
the idea of you going in and negotiating
and trying
my friend bought them for a special he
never warmed I don't care behind you
you're standing there going I wanna
trade the next big like shoe launch and
like go to the cash register and instead
of trying to pay for it yeah okay yeah
well like I said I dumped some space
jams and some others yeah yeah the
Elevens right yeah everywhere so I but I
didn't make any money I I broke even or
you could have made money for all yes I
had three pairs I got too many sneakers
at home I got one pair I wish I had more
if I had more than one pair that fit me
cuz I save everything I were in a
special dress do one pair clothes I save
if I had more than one pair that fit me
I'd wear them but I just I only have the
one pair that actually was my right size
I wore for this I save everything from
TV there's stuff I Ward evening at
improv which it was a noose and then I
went to hey I want to go take his Yeezys
that he gave me to the store that you
know last time boss was here you gave
him the easies cuz Norton had bought a
whole bunch of Yeezys to wear on his
special and we had one here right so
there's a place rich we gave it to rich
because I wasn't gonna sell him you just
don't know the culture yeah I said I
don't know if I got like six seven
hundred for so rich is gonna sell them
and look good money yes put the money
because they aren't there like something
that they're not new user one of the
originals are probably go for like 600
second I bought him in a store mhm I
took him out of the box the guy looked
at it for one second and one fakes but
why do you have them I do I did wear
them on my special I haven't bought a
bunch of sizes they cost me some I mean
it was twenty bucks a piece of paper
you owe me an hour no and they were like
really big because I don't know anything
about those sneakers like if they were
Irish but there's little things you
might know like the back to bugger the
box there's nothing on them I know I was
going this is not it's a cardboard box
with tape on it was held together with
duct tape on oh you did I I thought
maybe you bought a bunch of pairs just
do them in a bow okay did it did it
worry you at all that there was a Asian
writing written on the card and I didn't
even see that
this isn't even a shoebox and no I don't
he didn't put it in the box
yeah he said these are fake and medium
from maybe ten feet between us he knew
he could tell and I almost said oh yeah
well you I just say you're lying he's
famous and I was gonna call you to get
you on the phone but you know I wish you
would have listened to this like wicking
and stuff well you're gonna get me on
the phone yeah
I didn't you got you did you get
indignant tyne I did are you cause it
wasn't mine I didn't give up [ __ ] the
only thing that bothered me was that I
drove to New Brunswick I was like you
know it's not too it wasn't too many
warm days mom I still made it out to
play good at one o'clock instead of at
11:30 right and but I had to drive to
New Brunswick which is like 25 minutes
from my house it's an inconvenience
yeah yeah you should see the glue here
by the way where the so I don't know
anything I can see the glue I didn't
inspect the sneakers right I just put
that clear I don't know those sneakers I
never bought it he did he did it's not
even one part it's the entire side of
the shoe you can see the glue that
connects there's a bad sign on a show
yeah that's that's poor quality what
size a day that's probably seven they
might fit you Denny you want to try them
on you want to rock some [ __ ] Nazis
yeah some feces right these feces sure
don't fit him thank you he's a nice
did you feel silly like so at no point
did you realize I turn around and walked
out quick
you did what frauds in my hand Jim and I
we've been giggling for two weeks yeah
oh yeah we all like we say on the air
but when we gave you the shoes that day
in studio like both of us had to avoid
eye contact with you and with each other
cuz neither one of us could keep a
straight face a lot it's mean you have
fake they were if they were if they were
one Jorah Levin's I would have seen her
right away sure I've never seen a pair
of those you know feces yes thank you so
I am on time on Dennis hey what happened
is it did you turn down the tunes oh
yeah okay no no I just didn't want these
guys really pulled one over on me I'll
tell you that we did yes one [ __ ] shoe
store 25 oh yeah and you actually went
up to a shoe store and said excuse me
I'd like to sell me after they don't buy
real sure not only I Drive there I don't
we finish out front for the store to
open or sewer and I'm standing out there
in a new bundle with a bunch of thugs
and I'm we're wearing real sneakers and
you worried do yourself oh man I hope
nobody Rob's me for these very valuable
sneak wear no legs where are new but if
you had got your Rolex stolen
would that make you happy if he had his
tooth knocked out as well as taking
ecstatic to Titan wait hold on rich rich
what did you say it's insured yeah yeah
what does that mean just thought it
would add to the human kidding aside I
have insurance
let me tell you how dumb and stupid my
wife is remember when I did you tell her
do you know the shoes Rafi knows what
are you doing I said I I'm sellin eating
me and Nora spent the money and I loved
that too that he liked willing to go to
all this trouble
split the money on those sneakers and
then he still finds out their face do
you know how hard it was there Fugazi
stay what so after after the show that
day rich comes into the office oh no and
he doesn't have the box
oh you're right and I said rich where
are your shoes and you've never seen
someone run back to the back and then he
comes back because I oh I almost Oh Jim
hundreds of dollars if Richard lost the
shoes and said look I want to pay you
for him would you have let him yep we
were gonna get six hundred minimum right
so I'll take 250 or 300 I would take it
250 drop in the bucket I left him in the
bathroom I'm sure nobody grabbed him
they didn't see this anonymous cardboard
box with tape on an Asian writing well I
put themselves in open what about this
packing tape yeah the packing tape was
ready it's not is the packing tape
really baby you didn't know no the prank
tapes actually it's it's ripped here
that's very yellowed there's Kanye West
known for being a high fashion Bryant
sort of I clash and he's been a
fashionista he would not approve this no
he was not I just thought it was a box
from home which I totally bought like
eight pairs and they so are you gonna
say rich about the you're gonna say by
the insurance then you at all and um
your wife is yeah why is she stupid so
Jim the other night I go yeah we got to
by the way you can get the shoes that
gym shoes are modeled off of for sixteen
hundred dollars off goat goat is an app
and they're going for sixteen hundred
yeah damn I would have taken six